all right very sweet message by drug
Checkmate that I want to read out love
you Sensei not only helping me improving
so much but gave me a deep deeper
understanding of Chess in general mostly
with your YouTube content playing chess
since a year now started at 30 years old
I'm now around 1500 still improving
you're the best chess teacher imagine
well thank you very much that is very
touching and uh that is the goal of the
channel to deepen people's understanding
of the game wherever you are in your
chess Journey
that is very sweet thank you
[Music]
all right guys let's uh roll the cameras
get started with another Speed Run game
I guess I'll start the video here I
wanted to start with a clarification
this is hilarious for me to say but in
the last video which was released um
which I broke up into two parts the game
occupies one entire video because it was
so long then the analysis will come out
in a later video this was the grunfeld
game called what is a tabia
I joked about some idiot named Vladimir
kramnik obviously I was being fully
sarcastic I love kramnik but I was
flabbergasted to see that in the
comments like at least 10 people took
that comment seriously
and not even in a sarcastic way
themselves like clearly people were put
off by that joke just wanted to clarify
that that is a joke I would never call
someone like kramnik an idiot and
hopefully people who've watched more
than one of my videos like knows that
sometimes I
say things in a very deadpan way that's
just the way that I was that's the kind
of humor that I was raised with so I
can't really help it
all right with that out of the way let's
get the game underway
I would not call crime like an idiot in
like even if I thought that which I
don't I wouldn't do it on like my
YouTube channel
okay and we are playing shepparton from
Turkey
let's play E4 we have the white pieces
and we get E4 E5 so I put a lot of
thought into what my quote unquote
official recommendation is against D5
and it's going to be a combination of
the two main openings that I have played
throughout all of the speedruns you
might remember that in the previous
Speed Run we focused on the four night
scotch and of course the second
recommendation is also what Levy
recommends in his E4 course and that is
the Vienna we've played the Vienna thus
far I'd like to play the fortnite scotch
for some variety and the fortnite scotch
has yielded incredible results for us
really all the way under 2 000 people
just don't study it people don't know
how to play it and even though it has a
reputation as a quote-unquote boring or
Josh opening it really isn't and all of
that is a moot point because we're
facing the filador unfortunately we'll
have to save that conversation for
another day but it's definitely
worthwhile to know how to face the
Philadelphia the move D6 has a pretty
shoddy reputation
for good reason somewhat I mean the
Philadelphia is obviously much inferior
to both Knight C6 and Knight F6 which is
the Petrov but you still have to know
how to play against it and the the game
isn't going to win itself
the basic positional drawback of the
move D6 is a that it closes down the
bishop and black is going to struggle
with that Bishop for a long time and B
on a simpler level that black simply
does not develop his pieces and and when
you're playing Black you don't really
have the luxury of of pushing pawns too
many times so black immediately falls
behind in development now the way that
most books recommend white to play the
philidor is the immediate d2d4
counter-striking in the center but
there's a very similar system it often
transposes into the D4 line because we
do end up playing D4 most of the time
but I really like this move order
because it's incredibly tricky it sets
an immediate trap a lot of Philadelphia
players feel very disconcerted when
white doesn't play D4 and that's
actually to start with Bishop to C4 I
learned this from Gary Kasparov uh he
had an early game in the 80s where he he
played the system
and I really liked it and because Farm
actually played it with D3 which is a
way to transpose the game into an
Italian but we're not gonna play D3
we're gonna play this with D4 and before
we play D4 wow that even Rhymes we first
are going to complete our Queen side
development we're going to play Knight
to C3
and then we're very likely going to
Castle or we can play D4 on the next
move the move order in this line it
essentially doesn't matter as long as
you play D4 in a timely fashion uh your
your position is going to be good
okay I think this is probably as good of
an opportunity as any uh to push D4
so we can also Castle first we can even
play a quieter move like H3 but I like
the look of D4 in this position so let's
go for it opening up the center
black takes on D4 this is still Theory
Knight takes D4
and after black castles there is one
trick that you have to be very aware of
in any situation where you've got your
pieces arranged like this what am I
talking about like if black if White
Castle's here black has a rather nasty
little trick that enables him to solve a
lot of his opening problems it's called
the center fork trick and I've talked
about it pretty extensively before
because it's so Universal it occurs in
almost every opening what I'm talking
about is Knight takes E4 and after
Knight takes E4 D5 black Forks two of
White's minor pieces now it's not the
end of the world because in that
resulting position you can for example
drop your Bishop back to D3
and you keep your Bishop pair and after
de4 Bishop takes E4 we have three miners
against three miners the problem is that
the center dissipates and if you think
about it on a strategic level giving up
the E4 Pawn for the D6 Pawn is not a
very good trade because then Black's
Bishop opens up and you know the whole
basis of our advantage is the fact that
we've got Superior central control and
better placed pieces so how do we avoid
the center fork trick well you might
think that the best way to do it is F3
but I don't really like the look of F3
because it's weakening and we haven't
castled yet and I think there is a much
more watertight way to take the sting
out of Knight takes E4 and that is
simply to move the bishop away but not
to D3 right if we're moving the bishop
to D3 why did we develop it to C4 in the
first place well we developed it to C4
in order to stay on this diagonal so I
much prefer the move Bishop to B3 and
you might think well but isn't the pawn
going to be weak well maybe it is for
two moves but we're going to defend that
pawn a million different ways after we
Castle we can play rookie one we still
can play F3 at some later points so I
would not worry too much about this Pawn
being weak black can't really attack it
in any effective manner A6 by our
opponent clearly preparing to expand on
the queen side with B5
which is a good move I think our
opponent is handling the opening very
well
and I mentioned previously that you
should not automatically play A4 in
response to A6 that there are some
situations
in which you actually want to invite the
move B5 and then play A4 in response to
B5 kind of shattering your opponent's
Pawn chain the problem with allowing B5
in this position is that let's say we
Castle on black plays B5 if we play A4
there black can actually push the C Pawn
up to C5 chasing with a knight and once
the Knight moves black drives the pawn
down to C4 that doesn't trap the bishop
the bishop still has the A2 square but
things get very concrete there and the
bishop gets locked out of the game and I
I'm not in the mood for a struggle
that's this concrete and this tactical
this early in the game we don't want to
give black what he wants so I quite like
the look of A4 A3 is also possible but
A4 prevents B5 and
that's the more direct prophylactic move
Bishop to D7 okay now I think we should
continue our development by castling we
are not afraid of C5 you know this is a
move a lot of people in the 13 1400
range like to make in general the move
C5 is a huge positional mistake because
it creates a massive weakness on D6
that's a backward pawn and when you have
a backward Pawn there's usually a square
in front of it that's also going to be a
weakness we can use the D5 Square as an
outpost so you're not afraid of C5
classic case of one move it is our
opponent continues to handle the
position well Knight to C6 okay
so now we have our first tension in the
center right the knights are staring at
each other and the immediate question is
well should we take on C6 should we move
the Knight away should we not react at
all and generally the third option is
going to be best we are not afraid of
Knight takes D4 and you might say well
what about Knight takes D4 and then C5
well we're still not afraid of that
we're just going to drop our Queen back
and again C5 is bad for the same reasons
that it was bad a move previously so we
can continue improving our position as
if nothing is happening because nothing
is happening and the move that I like to
play preliminarily right a move that I
like to play before deciding where we
develop our Bishop is just this General
improving move rookie one it's good
practice to play this move in a lot of
different types of positions our
opponent takes on D4 and I think we're
gonna see C5 no Bishop C6 okay
and of course white is slightly better I
mean there's no doubt and there should
be no doubt in your mind that white is
better here we've got better placed
visas we've got a better Center but
Black's position is incredibly solid
black has no weaknesses and it's always
hard to make progress in a position
where your opponent has no weaknesses
you have to be very patient you have to
be methodical and you have to avoid
thinking that you are winning or
anything of the sort just because you
have more space and better central
control now there's many ways that we
could handle this position it's a pretty
open-ended position in the sense that I
would say there's probably three or four
decent moves on every turn
but our next order of business is to
decide where to position this bishop
Bishop G5 might strike you as the most
natural move but then I don't like the
prospect of black moving the Knight away
and offering a trade of Bishops trades
in general favor the side that has a
space disadvantage plus the bishop on E7
is a dud
so I much prefer to put the bishop on F4
and I'll delve into the the sort of
rationale behind this move properly
after the game because it appears that
the bishop bites on granite here I would
say that the the Distributing the
coveted vaccine rule applies where it's
not the greatest Bishop in the world but
at least our Rooks are coordinated I got
to give a lot of credit to our upon me
he knows all of the typical ideas and
the Philadelphia Knight F6 to D7 is a
great move preparing to delve into C5
also preparing Bishop to F6
so what I'd like to do now
is preemptively moved the queen away
from D4 because otherwise Bishop to F6
is going to come with Tempo so I think
the move Queen D2 is a prudent kind of
prophylactic move because we're largely
forcing black to put his cards on the
table so let's let's start by dropping
the queen back to D2 we're also
preventing Bishop to G5 which would have
been a rather annoying way that black
could have proposed a trade of dark
squared Bishops and again we generally
want to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible because we have a space
Advantage other ideas that are
circulating in my mind are well we've
got the Rook lift Rook E3 Rook G3 we
could try and attack against Black's
King
but I think we should try to play more
positionally because attacking Black's
King here is going to be very difficult
Black's got a lot of pieces in the
vicinity of the king side we don't have
that many attacking forces I mean yeah
even if we get the Rook to G3 even if we
get to play Bishop to H6 black can
always drop the Knight back to G6 and
cover the G file so I think we should
play in the center because the center is
where we have our biggest superiority
right we have a pawn in the center and
black really doesn't so there's a move
here that's coming to my mind it's a
very natural move and I think it's a
very good move it's a move that
essentially forces black to give away
either the light squared bishop or the
dark squirt bishop and it's a move that
comes with a a very small price tag
right this move does not make any
concessions it just applies more
pressure in the center what am I talking
about talking of course about the move
Knight to D5 and we are going to have to
speed up a little bit because our
opponent is playing almost instantly
so you might look at this move and say
well didn't you just say that you don't
want to allow the trade of minor pieces
but clearly this is different because
here we are getting rid of arguably
Black's strongest piece that Bishop on
C6 was very nicely centralized and we
gain the bishop pair which in an open
position is a pretty good idea let's
take back with a bishop and attack B7 we
don't want to take back with the pawn
because then The Bishop's gonna start
complaining okay so black has played C6
we move our Bishop back and we have
officially induced finally our first
weakness that pod on D6 is now a
backward Pawn I've talked about it a
little bit before and when you induce a
weakness that's in the center it's easy
to attack and often your subsequent
moves just flow naturally from that
observation right the weakness has been
created so that now the move is
painfully obvious
which is to play Rook 81 and that's it
we've created our first threat of the
game we're attacking D6 and it's not
that easy to defend that pawn and I
think our opponent common mistake failed
to understand how pushing a pawn impacts
the position right he played C6 kind of
nonchalantly without realizing that now
the D6 Pawn is a huge liability and it
can barely be defended I mean black
might have to go back to E7 but if he
has to do that that means we have
essentially won the opening battle given
the opportunity we we obviously will
take on D6 and we will still have to
convert an extra Pawn in that subsequent
end game which is not going to be easy
as our opponent is thinking I'm
generating other possible ideas that
could improve our position one way in
which we could take the bite out of the
bishop is with this classic move C3
building a little bull work with our
Pawn so upon so that the bishop bites on
granite
now C3 has the downside of leaving the
bishop undefended and maybe in
retrospect it was better to tuck it away
on A2 when we had a chance
but again and again and again you should
not be afraid of one move threats just
because they're one move threats and so
after C3 Queen B6 attacks the bishop but
the bishop has plenty of retreating
squares so as you move to 1600 and above
you should try to understand that you
know these principles and these
guidelines
very often they can be violated the
strongest players know exactly when to
violate them all right Knight G6 really
hastens the process it not only allows
us to take the pawn but allows us to do
so with Tempo attacking The Rook as we
do so
and now black is in real trouble
it's interesting how quickly Black's
position starts to deteriorate here
so we're gonna okay Ricky
now we've already moved to sort of the
technical stage
are many ways I think in which we could
continue
to convert our advantage there's more
tactical approaches more concrete
approaches and then there are more
positional approaches move slower moves
moves that aim for an end game and what
do I see here well okay we have won the
pawn on D6 what is the consequence of
that well the consequence of that is
that now there is a distinct possibility
of basically shoving this Pawn down
Black's throat E4 E5 is very close to
working now clearly it doesn't work yet
because black has one two three
Defenders on that square and we have
only two attackers but there's a natural
idea that stems from that which is to
play F2 F4 yes we weaken our King
slightly but the king can always hide
away on H1 I'm not scared of that and if
we can squeeze E5 through I mean it
should just be evident to you that that
pawn chain is devastating we could
follow up with F5 and just knock all of
flex pieces off the board
now F4 does come with a price tag which
is that we blunder well we don't want to
we give away the pawn on B2 and the
issue is that if we play C3 in that
resulting position to try to trap the
bishop then black has the check on B6
for King The King and the bishop notice
that I made this observation a little
bit earlier and now it helps us not
blunder right the moment we play C3 we
have to pay attention to that Bishop on
B3 and if we play F4 we have to pay
attention to the diagonal that we open
up so if we play F4 and black takes on
B2 most likely we're just gonna have to
continue with our plan with E5 but the
reason I really like that is because E5
also locks the bishop out of the game it
it forces the bishop to remain in jail
on B2 and even if our attack on the king
side and in the center doesn't work out
we could basically just hunt for that
Bishop we could go something as simple
as Rook to B1 on the next move and the
bishop is going to be trapped so to me
F4 is almost a no-brainer
now you could have taken a more Slow
Burn approach after the game I'll show
you some Alternatives in this position
that caught my eye Queen to B4 is a move
that I think a lot of you probably
didn't pay attention to but that
produces it's a high quality move as
well because it opens up a direct
connection between your rook and black
screen that's how I saw it
but I think F4 is definitely the
principled way to try to convert the
advantage quickly and efficiently
all right
if you did see Queen before and
skeptical gun deserves a sub oh he's
already a sub Queen B4 was mentioned in
the chat good job that is that is a
classy move right there classy move
okay
Bishop back to E7 good move by our
opponent I think that is the only way
that black can essentially stay in the
game
all right so
now it's important not to panic here not
to get overwhelmed by sort of the amount
of stuff that's going on if you approach
the position methodically you can make
the sort of task of searching for a move
quite a bit easier
let me think for a second I there's a
couple of Canada moves here that I need
to sort through
okay but I think it's pretty clear to me
that what we do not want to do is just
give up this incredibly strong Bishop on
D6 we have a great opportunity to trade
on our own terms with the move E5 and
should black take on D6 we can take with
the pawn and I mean look at that pawn on
D6 it's two steps away from promotion
that is the pawn we definitely want to
get and it's also very well defended by
the queen and the Rook on D1 so it seems
to me that E5 can be played largely
without calculation
some of you were tempted by F5
and you might have calculated Bishop
takes bishop and then Pawn takes Knight
when it appears that white has two
threats I'll delve into that after the
game I'll show you why I didn't like it
I saw Ro K4 Queen takes D6 also possible
but we're gonna save some time by taking
quickly with the pawn this I mean a pawn
like this just uh has to be has to be
good okay so what do we take with well
we definitely should take with the Rook
because if we take with the Rook the
great thing about that is that the Rook
is a much better infiltrator generally
speaking than the queen because it's the
less valuable piece
so here we actually violate the rule
and I've shared this rule before that
rule basically states that you should
accomplish certain tasks with the piece
of lowest value in order to Leave the
Pieces of highest value free to do the
important stuff and you might say well
shouldn't we leave The Rook the menial
task of Defending D6 well the mistake
there is to say that defending D6 is
like a menial task it's not it's
actually the most important task on the
board defending these two pawns and
preventing Black's pieces from getting
active as long as D6 is defended the
other pieces have essentially the easy
job
now we're not threatening Rook to E7
here but what we do want to do is push
F5 knock the Knight off of G6 and then
infiltrate to E7
our opponent plays Queen F6 abandoning
the pawn on D7 sorry abandoning the pawn
on D6 so it seems to me
that D7 probably should win the game let
me think about this for a second because
there is one tactical subtlety we have
to account for there
it's not as easy as it seems
hmm so D7
Rook d8 that's the annoying move
then we play Queen before
yeah Queen B4 there might be an
important resource
Knight Faye Rook E8 okay let's start
with D7 I mean this cannot be a bad move
I'm trying to figure out the win after
Rook to d8 it's not as easy as it seems
okay I found it
after Rook d8 the win is very
instructive but let's hope let's hope
our opponent plays Rook d8
I don't see another move
because Knight G6 to E7 blocks The Rook
obviously the threat is rookie eight
everybody should see that rookie 8 is
not mate black has Knight f8 the problem
is that the Rook on A8 is simply
unprotected
so black has to bring the Rook to a
defended Square so that after rookie 8
he can meet that with Knight of fate and
I still think a lot of players would go
wrong in that position but we have a
very clinical winning move
so her opponent finally thinking yes
Rook data is on the board
so
okay
what is the worst case scenario for
white well the worst case scenario is
that we lose the D6 the D7 pawn and you
might say well how could that possibly
happen well that's closer to happening
than you might think
take a look at this line rookie 8 check
Knight f8 and then you play the obvious
move and take the Rook well after Queen
takes the eight you actually cannot
defend the D7 Pawn
black attacks it with the Knight and the
queen and the bishop has no way to
squeeze itself to you know E6 or any
square like that
so we go back to the last position in
which we had a choice after rookie a
check Knight f8 we should pause for a
second and consider whether we have any
other candidate moves now there are two
ways to approach that position we can
try to attack The Rook
dislodge The Rook from d8 so that we can
then promote the pawn so the move that
comes to mind is rookie 8 Knight f8 and
then Queen to A5 but the problem is that
we relinquish our defense of the D7 Pawn
that ain't gonna work
the second way to approach this is to go
from the other side and try to attack
the Knight and if you ask yourself that
specific question how can I attack the
Knight after rookie 8 Knight f8 you
should immediately see the move well you
should see Queen D6 but Queen D6 doesn't
work because black controls that square
but can you play a different move on the
same diagonal yes you can you can play
Queen to B4
and I really you know belabored the
point there because it's a very easy
move to miss and it's a hard move to
find unless you're sort of specifically
looking for a way to attack the Knight
but Queen before I think is the only
winning move the only move that wins
cleanly in this position
black has nothing to put between the
queen and the Knight C5 we just play
Queen takes C5 we are threatening Queen
takes f8
if black takes the Rook then we take
back with a new Queen
and all black can do is Stave off
checkmate
a nice little move
Queen to B4 that's the killer absolute
killer
a short game
but I think a very nice illustration of
how quickly
one's position can deteriorate when a
weakness is made
so anti-climactic in some ways but
instructive in others and there's a
couple moments I want to discuss after
the game particularly opening because I
will admit that I I think I messed
something up a little bit in the opening
I didn't get exactly the kind of
position that I wanted
so we'll definitely take a careful look
with the engine and I will make sort of
a more informed recommendation against
the Philadelphia
yeah now our opponent starts thinking
but it is a little bit too late just a
little bit too late
yeah the thing is our opponent played
Bullet at the start of the game which
was more Justified because he knew what
he was doing
but when we went to like move 14 move 15
the situation started heating up and
you know black continued to play
instantly which was not justified
okay
but I also want to make the point that
if your opponent is playing instantly
that should really not affect your time
management and I still see a lot of
players who fall for the sort of
provocation right their opponent plays
instantly this happens over the board as
well a lot with young players opponent
plays quickly and then you play quickly
as a result you really have to resist
that Temptation if your time management
is good it shouldn't matter that you
have seven minutes less than your
opponent because you've been putting
more thought into your moves so your
position should reflect that
yeah Forever YouTube says do I resign or
do I play C5 Queen takes C5 and resign
all right very sweet message by
um
drug Checkmate that I want to read out
love you Sensei not only helping me
improving so much but gave me a deep
deeper understanding of Chess in general
mostly with your YouTube content playing
just since a year now started at 30
years old I'm now around 1500 still
improving you're the best chess teacher
imagine well thank you very much that is
very touching that is the goal of the
channel to deepen people's understanding
of the game wherever you are in your
chess Journey
that is very sweet thank you
okay so what we are going to do
is we are going to well I'm going to
pull up chest space and stockfish and
then I'm going to reflect the moves onto
the chess.com board so let's go back to
the start
and let's examine the opening with a
fine tooth comb so Bishop C4 is
definitely a move
that I would recommend I mean listen if
you want to play the top engine move
then you should definitely play D4 D4 is
the more topical move
the thing is after D4 there's actually
quite a bit of theory and as far as I
know the sort of official recommendation
that is made by it's made by Pari marja
Negi the Indian Grandmaster in his very
well-known E4 series I don't know what
Wesley so recommends against the
Philadelphia in his chessable
series I mean that's something you can
check what I do know is that the modern
treatment of the philidor is mostly to
play Knight F6 and then Bishop to E7 and
I remember that Negi recommends the move
Bishop to F4 and I'm checking that this
is also at least at a relatively low
depth the main stockfish recommendation
and the bottom line is that you just go
Queen to D2 and then you Castle Queen
side and then you try to Steamroller
black on the other side of the board but
this kind of plays not to everyone's
liking for example there's the move D5
and here you have to know a a good deal
of theory things get actually very crazy
because as far as I know the move is
Knight D to B5
and then black pins the other night with
Bishop B4 and then Knight C7 Knight E4
so this is very sharp but I would invite
you to analyze this with an engine on
your own if you really want the to
squeeze the most out of the position
this bishop F4 line is how you want to
do it you should also check the move G6
which is an alternate but but here it's
like a bad dragon and I think white
plays this in the same way that he plays
a Mainline Dragon where you play Bishop
E3 F3 and queen D2
anyways let's see if Bishop C4 is worth
its salt so Bishop C4
Bishop to E7
Knight to C3 is fine Knight to F6
and now let's see yeah D4 is all again
the top move
C4 Ed Knight takes D4
black castles
oh now this is very interesting so in
this position
I've let the engine sit a little bit
and stockfish seems to believe that you
should actually allow the center fork
trick that you should play castles
very interesting and here's what happens
Knight takes C4
now you play Knight takes E4 black plays
D5 and this was a case of Miss
evaluating the position I just sort of
assumed
that the position is going to be equal
after black takes the Knight back but in
reality according to the engine
this is right around 0.4 for White and
the reason why is pretty simple White's
got two pieces in the center and black
has zero White's got two pieces
developed and black has one black has
some trouble developing his light
squared Bishop so one logical move for
black would be to play the move C6
and try to ensure that White's Bishop
bites on granite the problem is the
bishop has the other diagonal that it's
controlling
and I'm running a search on games in
this position so it'll just take a
second
actually let me stop that because I do
want to check what the engine says here
okay so 94 94 D5 Bishop D3 takes takes
C6 not the best move
okay white plays C3
solidifying the Knight
now let's say the black develops his
Knight to D7
let's see
oh why does a win oh there's a beautiful
move here see this is a direct product
of having pieces in the center who can
spot the very pretty tactic out of a
clear blue sky white is already almost
winning here Bishop takes C6
way of Kings I would not have seen that
in a Blitz game
BC Knight C6 Fork now you might say oh
but Queen E8 defends the bishop No
rookie one wins the bishop back and
White's gonna be two pawns up Knight to
E5 is a tricky little move
and here you can actually take with
either piece even The Rook because
Bishop hangs but 95 is the better move
and White's two pawns up
so that's the reason black is a hard
time developing her pieces
here black should play a move like
Bishop to F6 sort of procrastinating
because well because you can't
bring the Knight on you have nowhere
good to bring the light squid Bishop out
and white improves uh the position where
the rookie one
white is better yeah and here after
Knight D7 we play Bishop F4 and you
should just see that whatever black does
there's gonna be tactics waiting for
them after Knight C5 there's this tactic
Bishop H7 and you pick off the Knight so
White's position has actually a lot of
potential and it's not easy to play for
black C6 here turns out to be a mistake
and to me it's a very natural move the
best move is Knight to D7 immediately
and the point being you're going to
bring the Knight and swing it over to F6
white plays for example C3 the engine
recommends and after Knight F6 tuck the
bishop back in this little envelope on
C2
and white is slightly better 0.3.4 it's
a more pleasant position to play and if
black plays an in cautious move like C5
White's Knight lands on F5 and here
obviously white is better because you
have the bishop pair and black has some
Queen side weaknesses so this is a
simple way to play
against Knight takes C4 and this would
have been more effective than wasting a
move on Bishop to B3
very interesting Insight I never knew
that so after Bishop to B3 black played
the move A6 which is decent according to
the computer but C5 actually equalizes
and this is really interesting because
from a positional standpoint C5 is the
terrible move but here's what the engine
gives what it gives is after Knight de2
Knight comes out to C6 and it's just a
very very concrete idea black plays A6
much like our opponent played but with
the move order changed and after a6a4
how does black insist on carrying out
the B5 pondering who can tell me sort of
a very typical move you also see this
idea in the Sicilian where Black Ops for
Queen side expansion I'm talking like
closed Sicilian or Grand Prix attack
what's the best way to prepare B5 yeah
it's to play the simple Rook to B8
notice that white cannot play the
typical A5 which would nip B5 in the bud
because the pawn hangs
that's one of the positive byproducts of
playing C5 the way I would explain why
the position is equal is that blacks
very effective Queen side Play Once
black plays B5 these pawns are going to
be very menacing and they can further
Advance towards C4 compensates for the
fact that black has a very weak Square
on D5 and a bad Pawn on D6 so when a
position is equal right there's
different types of equality in an
asymmetric position one in which there's
no Pawn structural symmetry if the
computer gives equality it's usually
because the chances for both sides are
kind of counter balancing each other
what one side is one idea and one
drawback the other side has different
assets and different drawbacks to their
position so for instance the computer's
Main Line it goes Bishop to F4 black
doesn't have to rush with B5 the engine
actually gives this funny move Knight H5
getting the bishop off of the F4 square
and decreasing the pressure on the D6
pawn and here black can just go back to
F6 and if white plays a move like H3
then already it's time for B5 and black
is a very comfortable position
so this is quite interesting the move C5
has anti-positional as it appears
actually would have been the best way to
equalize after a6a4 again black has the
move C5
but instead our opponent takes a
different approach he plays Bishop D7
and develops the Knight to C6 and this
of course is somewhat passive okay now
we can switch from engine analysis to
kind of human analysis
so here I decided on the Mover key one
our opponent takes on D4 we take back
with the queen and already here C5 is
not as good who can tell me where should
the queen go in this position and why
and if you've paid attention to sort of
just now the analysis then you should
this should be automatic where should
the queen go D1 E3 somewhere else
not C4 although you're on the right
track
yeah it should go to D3 so the reasoning
is correct you should try to prevent B5
and here if flag plays Rook B8 we can
actually go A5 or we can even go Bishop
F4 and White's attack comes first
because the bishop is so awkward on D7
so why not Queen C4 because the queen of
C4 is very vulnerable this is the
concept of the queen as the supporting
actress as Yasser sarawan likes to put
it the further into your opponent's
territory your queen is the more
vulnerable it becomes so the queen on C4
is a lot more susceptible to various
annoying moves as compared to the queen
on D3 and you should be able to see that
in fact B5 is already a move you have to
consider it doesn't quite work but it's
annoying because it attacks the queen
Bishop E6 is another annoying move
so white preserves the advantage but
Queen D3 is more clinical and that
should generally be your your
inclination okay so our opponent goes
Bishop C6
okay white is slightly better here it's
about point four and this is how I also
evaluated during the game Knight D7 is a
great move though now we drop our Queen
back to D2
and uh our opponent goes 95 which I
actually think is a mistake
I actually think 95 is a serious
positional transgression why how on
Earth could it be a mistake to
centralize the night in this very
natural fashion I think there are two
reasons that this move is a mistake so
first of all it's because it allows us
to position our own Knight on D5 and
immediately put pressure on Black's
pieces right this induces a concession
forcibly because black can't hold both
of his Bishops alive
instead of 95 I think a much more
effective move would have been to first
play Bishop F6
and the idea of this move is to prevent
our knight from jumping into D5 that
would blunder the B2 Pawn
in response to this move I would have
played rookated D1 and rather than going
to E5 and blocking his own Bishop it
would have been a better idea to go
Knight cc5 this is a more effective way
to Target White's Center because you're
already threatening to win a pawn
so a move like Knight C5 here it still
doesn't really work because B2 hangs
and you can't really go C3 because this
bishop hangs so concretely things work
out we would have had to play a move
like F3 here and now black can snap off
the bishop and then just continue going
along with the position with a move like
rookie and I think this is closer to
equality than to anything else
and interestingly the engine believes
that we should not have procrastinated
and we should have played Knight D5
immediately so procrastinating for one
move would have allowed black to
position the bishopod F6 and prevent
Knight D5 hopefully that makes sense
Knight C5 immediately is also a good
move but I think this gives the extra
option of Bishop to D5 a little nasty
move
whereas Bishop dd5 here uh black can
take it and again Knight D5 B2 hangs
so the takeaway here is that in these
quiet positions things are really
decided by these subtleties you know
which piece do you position on a square
first and they're important but they're
not inaccessible even if you're
relatively a beginner you should
understand why Bishop F6 is a better
move than Knight E5 and the other
takeaway is that just putting your
pieces in the center just because isn't
always a good strategy you need to
understand what a piece is doing on a
particular square and if you think about
the Knight it's not actually doing all
that much because all of the squares
that it could potentially access are
controlled by White's pieces and Pawns
so we played Knight D5 and already after
the trade I think white is clearly
better C6 to me is another inaccuracy
whoops I keep doing that perhaps black
should have played Rook B8 but this is
not an easy move to make yourself play
and after Rook 81 of obviously and white
is already doing great uh after C6
Bishop B3 the situation is already very
very difficult and black exacerbates it
with Bishop F6 because this walks right
into Rook 81 I think the way for black
to defend here is just to kind of grovel
with a move like Queen C7 and and take
care of your weakness keep your Bishop
on E7 it's the only main Defender
this I mean it's plus one or so
according to the engine which is
entirely sensible we probably would have
played a move like C3 sort of preempting
Bishop F6
and then we we can improve our position
in a million different ways we I would
make some Luft with H3 and eventually I
like the idea of moving the bishop back
and expanding on the king side with F4
much like we did in the game
so
this is a good position to kind of dig
around in if you want to get a better
sense of how to squeeze these types of
positional advantages but I won't delve
too deeply into this position suffice it
to say that y would have been clearly
better now here was Black's last chance
to keep a relatively tenable position of
course he had to go back to E7
and Mike Old Coach Gregory kaidanov used
to call this saying sorry where you make
a move and then you realize it was a
crappy move and then you just go back to
the initial square and in many cases
that is you know really the only thing
that that you can do
in any case Bishop E7 would have kept a
somewhat defensible position we would
have moved the queen away reinforcing
the threat of Bishop takes Knight maybe
the queen will swing to H5 but okay
black and hold on and obviously after he
gives up the pawn I'm checking the
engine and queen before indeed was the
top move Queen B4 is an incredibly
strong move because it hits B7 and opens
up a direct line of fire against Black's
Queen
and then after the queen moves away here
F4 is probably even stronger because we
have improved the placement of our Queen
okay but I think the move I played I'm
very happy with we're just directly
going for Black's throat
if Bishop takes B2 then we would have
simply gone E5 securing the bishop and
locking out Black's Bishop this is over
I mean first of all we're just
steamrolling him on the king side second
of all white is a really funny idea
so why does C3 not work well it's
because it blunders the bishop to Queen
B6 who can propose
this is actually the second move who can
propose a very much Russian Schoolboy
type of move here that wins the game
yeah it was King H1 just go King each
one prepare C3
bang that's it the bishop is lost the
game is won
oh black plays Queen B6 preemptively
then we could just say get off me A5
Queen tb5 Rook to B1 that's it if the
bishop has nowhere to move actually
Bishop is trapped even if it did we
would have Bishop sound
so King H1 here is a cute little move
so our opponent goes back which I think
is correct E5
Bishop D6 ed6 and this is lost I mean
this Pawn is just too much to bear
rookie one rookie one
FC yeah Rook V1 immediately was good
Queen F6 and of course D7 just push the
pawn but when I play this move I I
already had to see
I already I already had to see uh that
that Queen B4 was one was winning the
game because otherwise you can bite off
more than you can chew
so here I actually think rookie 8 and
queen B4 is not the only win but really
by far the most effective one we also
could have started with Queen before
this is also possible but less accurate
far less accurate because here black and
go H6
and black already creates a Luft Square
it's still winning according to the
engine but you still have some work to
do here you actually have to go back to
D2 in this case
and keep black confined so move order is
very important you have to induce Knight
f8 and then go Queen B4 and of course
the threat of Queen takes f8 is utterly
Unstoppable so if we count up the moves
it's only been 10 moves since black went
C6 I mean you compare this position with
this position it's like unrecognizable
but that's how quickly things tend to
happen when your opponent creates this
very very major weakness in the center
so one of the major takeaways of this
game is that any time a pawn is moved in
the center it sounds very primitive but
you have to reassess the pawn structure
and update your perception of the
weaknesses has your opponent created any
pawn weaknesses and if the answer is yes
how can I attack them how can I assemble
my pieces in such a way as to keep my
opponent tied down to the weakness and
mostly this method is effective when
your opponent creates weak Pawns in the
center if your opponent makes a move
that weakens some A7 Pawn in the corner
you have to be careful of assuming that
anytime you attack that pawn your
opponent is going to obediently defend
it but a center Pawn is far more
valuable we know that if the pawn on D6
collapses black soul position goes with
it as it did in the game
so remember that Center ponds are far
more likely to cause your opponent to be
tied down as opposed to some meaningless
Pawn in the corner
and of course King H1 is always a good
move that's the second moral of the
story but hopefully the opening analysis
made sense the conclusion is that in
this position it's a better idea to skip
to skip on Bishop B3 and just castle and
if black plays C6 then here again the
move A4 is rather effective because it
prevents B5 in the philidor structure
you generally do want to prevent black
from expanding on the queen side of B5
so a simple game but hopefully you
enjoyed it I think it nicely illustrates
some positional Concepts any questions
thank you everybody for participating
I know that I
really uh I was quite verbose in
explaining these Concepts but as we
enter 1600
what I'm trying to do in addition to the
main theme of the speedrun which is
opening emphasis is build up positional
understanding because this is where to
make it to 2000 you need a healthy dose
of positional understanding you need to
understand weaknesses and peace
placement and I'm going to really make
that emphasis as we go forward
thank you everybody for watching and for
hanging out see you guys later thanks
everybody bye
[Music]